bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
nuestra invitada del día de hoy es
leonardo bears miembro de la asamblea
legislativa de las islas falklands o
malvinas como son conocidas en la
argentina de una bienvenida y gracias
por estar con nosotros es un placer
estar con ustedes este año estamos
conmemorando el 40 aniversario del fin
de la guerra entre la argentina y el
reino unido- cuál es su gran recuerdo de
esa guerra
y
sólo tenía 10 años en la época de la
guerra
pero tengo recuerdos muy claros de lo
que fue una época horrible
creo que para mí los recuerdos más
fuertes son los del principio y los del
final la noche de la invasión fue
absolutamente aterradora no sabíamos que
iba a pasar y de repente encontramos
nuestra pequeña comunidad invadida por
tropas armadas y todas esas máquinas de
guerra por todas nuestras calles fue
horripilante y luego al final cuando la
batalla se acercó muchas tal y también
fue extremadamente aterrador
y siendo una niña de 10 años me hice a
la idea de que mi familia y yo podríamos
morir en los próximos días
así que son recuerdos muy difíciles para
ser sincera como esta guerra la afectó a
usted ya su familia
creo que afectó a toda la comunidad muy
drásticamente
hay algo en que alguien invada la casa
de uno que es imposible de describir
deja una verdadera cicatriz en el alma
de la gente y del país
pero creo que hemos trabajado muy duro
para salir adelante y no ser definidos
por eso
y desarrollar nuestro país lo mejor
posible fue un punto de inflexión para
todas las cosas
en su opinión cuáles son las grandes
lecciones que deja la guerra he hablado
con veteranos británicos que han dicho
que todo necesita hacerse para evadir un
conflicto
sí absolutamente trabó la guerra es algo
terrible no se lo desearía ni a mi peor
enemigo es algo horrible de vivir
y eso es desde la perspectiva de alguien
que fue una niña y una civil lo
lamentamos muy profundamente la guerra
por la sorbetera brusco por lo que
pasaron para asegurar nuestra libertad
creo que esa es la lección la guerra
nunca es la respuesta y es una tragedia
siempre que ocurre
estaba mencionando antes las
dificultades y cómo ha cambiado
cómo han cambiado las islas después de
la guerra cuéntenos por favor sobre esto
cómo ha cambiado la isla las islas
después de la guerra se ha cambiado
espectacularmente para ser sincera como
dije antes fue un punto de inflexión
para nosotros en los últimos 40 años
hemos trabajado muy duro para
desarrollar las islas y lo hemos hecho
con mucho éxito
entonces lo que era un lugar bastante
triste en cierto modo no sentíamos que
hubiera mucha esperanza mucha gente se
estaba yendo los años 70 y los
principios de los 80 fue una época muy
difícil pero desde entonces las islas se
han desarrollado masivamente
económicamente ahora tenemos una
economía muy fuerte y nuestra sociedad
ha crecido y se ha desarrollado ahora
somos muy multiculturales diversos y
abiertos lo cual es maravilloso y creo
que también somos un país muy fuerte
tenemos nuestra propia constitución las
focas tienen sus propias leyes somos
completamente independientes
financieramente del reino unido- no
recibimos dinero del gobierno británico
las islas están muy bien y tenemos un
futuro muy positivo y ambicioso por
delante para nuestro pequeño país como
debe ser eso nos entusiasma a todos cuál
es la actividad principal económica de
las islas la principal base de nuestra
economía es la pesca y así ha sido desde
mediados de los años 80 y nos ha ido muy
bien nos esforzamos mucho por proteger
la sostenibilidad de nuestras
poblaciones de peces así que invertimos
mucho dinero en la protección y el
seguimiento de las poblaciones para
asegurarnos de que estén ahí en el
futuro aparte de eso es al turismo y la
agricultura que históricamente ha sido
una de las principales industrias y
sigue siendo muy importante así es las
van bien llegan empresas y todo el
territorio está creciendo creo que hay
un verdadero sentimiento de optimismo
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson se reunió con el presidente de
la argentina alberto fernández durante
la cumbre del g7 en alemania según
downing street- boris johnson fue firme
en decir que la soberanía de las islas
no está en duda cuál es su opinión
esa declaración no me sorprendió como
habitante de las fobias
el gobierno británico se ha mantenido
absolutamente firme en decir que la
opinión de los isleños de las falklands
tiene que ser la cuestión crítica en
todo esto han sido muy claros al afirmar
que nosotros los habitantes de las
falklands
tenemos derecho a determinar su propio
futuro y sea lo que sea que deseemos en
el futuro
ya sea continuar nuestra asociación con
reino unido a la independencia lo que
sea es nuestra elección y ahí radica por
supuesto la diferencia con argentina que
no nos reconoce como pueblo y no
reconoce nuestro derecho a la
autodeterminación por lo tanto la
declaración no fue una sorpresa
fue muy grato escucharla de nuevo y que
se expresara con tanta claridad
cuál es la situación actual con la
argentina
la verdad es que es muy difícil y
seguimos siendo intimidados presionados
y amenazados por argentina hacen todo lo
posible para limitar nuestro crecimiento
económico social político y nuestras
conexiones con otros países así que es
muy difícil pero creo que para mí el
hecho de que simplemente rechacen el
hecho de que tenemos el derecho a la
autodeterminación a pesar de que por
ejemplo mi familia ha estado en las
filas durante nueve generaciones de que
construimos este país
ese es el asunto principal y ellos
simplemente no lo aceptan
entonces sigue siendo una situación
difícil en las folk las nos esforzamos
por trabajar con argentinas en
cuestiones de beneficio mutuo como la
protección de las poblaciones de peces
de la que hablé antes pero se han salido
de todos los acuerdos que existían al
respecto es muy triste
en el año 2013 hubo un referendo para
preguntarles a los isleños si querían
mantenerse como un territorio de
ultramar británico o no el 99.8 por
ciento votó por mantener el status quo
están planeando en hacer en realizar un
segundo referéndum
no creo que no sentimos la necesidad de
hacerlo no ha cambiado nada tenemos una
visión muy clara de lo que piensa
nuestro pueblo este referéndum fue
realmente para demostrar
en ese momento argentina decía muchas
cosas guardan una de las cosas más raras
que dijo fue que los isleños
estábamos esencialmente haciendo casi
que retenidos por el gobierno británico
queríamos desmentir eso así que dijimos
vamos a preguntarle a la gente
y así lo hicimos con una enorme
participación y un apoyo abrumadoramente
fuerte sólo tres personas votaron en
contra de mantener el estado eso envió
un mensaje muy claro debo decir que ese
referéndum fue observado por un equipo
internacional incluyendo un argentino
entonces no es algo que sintamos la
necesidad de repetir sabemos lo que
piensa nuestro pueblo
usted hace parte del grupo de
recuperación tras el cover cuál es la
situación con la pandemia con kobe en
las islas de transportes trabajaron muy
duro para mantener al covite fuera de
nuestro territorio tenemos recursos
médicos muy limitados en términos de
camas de cuidados intensivos por lo que
sentíamos que éramos bastante
vulnerables entonces rápidamente pusimos
en marcha medidas de control de
fronteras la cuarentena y todo lo demás
y conseguimos mantener el kobe fuera de
la comunidad durante dos años así que
relajamos las medidas en nuestras
fronteras y nuestra cuarentena justo a
principios de este año en mayo y ahora
hemos tenido transmisiones comunitarias
a más de la mitad de la población ha
tenido cobit ninguna enfermedad grave
ninguna muerte toco madera pero tenemos
una buena tasa de vacunación alrededor
del 96 por ciento de nuestra población
está vacunada
sí muy alta y eso nos dio la
tranquilidad para abrir nuestras
fronteras de nuevo porque de nuevo
estamos en una posición muy buena al
respecto como estamos superando parece
la pandemia del cob y 19 están planeando
ustedes promover están esperando que
haya mucho más turismo a las islas y son
los pingüinos la gran atracción
si esa es la respuesta fácil supongo en
particular el turismo de cruceros iba
muy bien antes del cob y recibíamos
entre 70.000 y 80.000 pasajeros de
cruceros en nuestra temporada de verano
obviamente durante dos años esto se
detuvo pero todo parece indicar que este
próximo verano recibiremos una gran
cantidad de visitantes y si todo el
mundo adora a nuestros pingüinos tenemos
cinco especies es muy fácil ir a verlos
y uno puede estar tan cerca de ellos
como lo estamos nosotros nuestra fauna
es impresionante la gente viene a ver
eso pero también es un país pequeño y
hermoso un aire limpio mares hermosos
hay muchas cosas que atraen a la gente
y unas rovers muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros ella es miembro de la
asamblea parlamentaria legislativa de
las islas falkland muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros y ustedes por
favor continúen en france 24 y france24
puntocom
con placer gracias
[Música]